There's a 16-year-old girl right
now, who's watching Gary Vee.
She's smart as fuck.
Her parents were in the
industry and she wants to do that
She's not going to sell for eight times Avada earned out over 40 like its net I've already done it
You ain't gotta be up in the office you rat trap it will be too costly
Talked about ownership and leverage 1800 sectors that out for average
you'll content out your ass as a human as
A human for you to be successful in how we see the world you don't even need the place
You can literally fucking start over and you'd win
That's why I'm the antichrist of you right because you probably put up billboards. Well. I mean if they were $10
I put them up one night right I would put up a thousand doors if they were free to me
It's not about anything's dead to me. It's what's the price three. I'll fuckin stand on a mountain do smoke signals
I'd be coming in here really nice to meet you a pleasure
Do you wear those kind of pants every day is that a thing more every day for 27 years the exact same outfit a shirt?
Clean white or just clean rain white sometimes with paint I put on clean shirt usually
Probably worst a huge mystery with our hands yeah. Yeah, that was cool. How are you good to see you you see
Oh yes, yes, I know right. How are you?
That was amazing please guys can stand well
oh
Man, it's good to see you again. Yeah. Thank yourself. What about this. What about your poor gary?
I agree. I'm trying to live to a thousand. I feel like I'm going to end up being yellow one day true, or do not
restraining up yeah
Like we crushed that right. I was smiling the whole time. We were doing. I'm like this dude has no idea
How good he's getting it like really don't go in that no
It's not that
Bad Aj they taught me to read play straight Pattern long
to be the people in the middle of like the businesses and the kids like when you think about the trade that you made with
Matt it's such a win for both parties
And that's fun in business like when both parties win at such an extreme level the fact that we're going to be able to
disproportionately impact small and medium sized businesses
Right and when I say medium sized businesses people doing 100 200 300 400 500 million in revenue
And we're going to be able to make kids who are not peyton manning right and you know and Joe Montana
You know hundreds of thousands of dollars off the field they would have never made in every single other agency combined
That's cool. The office can't be in there
exactly
It's brand. It's all the shit. I wanna do that's why I'm taking this mean
There's a fucking stupid meeting for me on paper
If I'm averaging my time but not for branding and opportunity and serendipity like you know the way the world actually works
If the world actually worked on math it would have been over by now
Right if it works on math, then people would have ran the algorithms and everything would be set right just not real life
There in place, did you successor?
Didn't success a thank you do give it to me
Only because we're building this whole thing for ourselves like the whole conglomerate is being built because I want to buy businesses
Told Journey is about building this machine and then buying the biggest businesses in the world
So I think we're so unique because our interests are aligning in a way that is very powerful
Because we're trying to figure it out for ourselves
India so work here remind you they killed Kenny
We only have three opposite once you have two human beings
You have you think we don't have characters? Well, that's right because I'm not a human being but damn
Well, thank you. Don't I say it. Thank you
I'm going to tell you bad whenever I come around I feel like a football
You've the good work. Thank you know if
It's a mentor. You're your mentor someone trying. You know because
You're good. You're very good at what you do. I appreciate it very good
Jesus fucking Christ this kind of flash
Jesus
You're available. It's october 24th and 25th doing a wine dinner. There would be amazing okay, because it's not as saturated as like
Yes, correct all auto. Send me Tyler and Kim an email, or did love you. Have multiple runs great
Are you sure to see me mark?
Marc Ecko wouldn't let you film. We said yeah, you look sad brown
Like things like this like midday like this way like I would have been fine like catching you like ad Avenu or two away
Every fucking minute man like you know I mean that
Am I in a hurry yeah?
Don't fuck up my shit
Hopping up before she goes to a crash like aeroponic man eager children a solution. Thank you guys
Can see for this school book women and time I am trying to give me doing what's in a Catholic no one for instance Bhajami
Like the leader brother cooper that lean on like a little fuchsia. They said
Shuttle compromise at my own feet so fucking focused Iraq, oh
whoa
good turn, I
Was exaggerating on purpose. Yes
Look Snapchat effect blowing up. Don't matter the crisis television my dreams
I'm confront in my life 22, and I'm talented I do not like it like
Three years if he was to start today on every single thing he did exactly the same way
What would you want your best guess that if you did everything exactly the same way with it it was he?
Quadruple where would you where would you be right now?
if I if I started today if you started today
And you actually did for three years you and your girls
account would combine to be what instead of four million your best guess three hundred thousand four hundred thousand ah
This is and and I love that
I had no idea what you're going to say, but I love that I would say we're in the same range
People don't understand. What moving quickly in
attention land Ships mean
You can be best and that's great, but there's just such a disproportionate
Amount of upside when you hit something, right?
and to our point from earlier about
Organic reach by Platform when I hopped on the platform trust me with not thirty five to fifty percent was closer closer to 100
so the the eyeballs were there in the beginning and as I will decrease the
potential for gaining a following
Organically on its own is very difficult
That's why we use influencers to be able to reach new markets that we can draw off to or Rim
Ray and they were coming at that organic reach variable and then answer game environment
Does it go to one to two percent like Facebook, maybe?
Maybe going on or hopefully so it just depends on how much Facebook stock you
all
You're welcome. Hey guys
How are you good? I like your sneakers by the way ah
Great, so thanks for being here. How's they going so far?
I think everybody the world's gonna do x is about jobs a
Job my preference is the vlog if you've got it in you, and by the way
It's pretty douchey to walk around with a human being filming you and I'm willing to be douchey more than anybody so you got to
Get over that hurdle first and that's a hurdle
But if you can do it, there's nothing close
Because then you've unlimited fucking content alright. I have to go
question
Eric
How are you very good good? It's a real finally meet you after all this time. I'm so excited right now
Yeah, your punk
That xx been great crush it. That's what we have
And you only 14 cents for using that bank? Oh, yeah?
Howdy how do I do you know you're the little context for this and obviously we share a lot of friends like?
we're I'm so motivated to help and
Then dan break and try and I think nobody you know
I think you've always notice nobody's going to intuitively understand it better than this organization. That's impossible. Yeah
So I think like I'm just excited I know no matter the righteous vision Monetary-Ism Conference in My life 22 another, Ellington
I do not like a vices appetite quanity champagne or anything. I get it solely
When I know there's a new frontier, right?
I'll actually give me my briefings like this thing you breezy get ready here
from Gary decreases five
Electro stop to me the land grab of intuitive consumer behavior in my life, and that's why I will only jet
I
Already know I fucked the whole Agency world
That's all I really wanted to do not because I'm not because not because because I'm going to take all their money
I'll never get around to it. It's because I've now shown people the path. There's no sixteenth. That's right
There's a sixteen-year-old girl right now. Who's watching Gary
Vee she's smartest fuck this is her parents were in the industry and she wants to do that
She and she's not going to sell for eight times the buddha earned out over four like it's net I've already done it in
entrepreneur never easier, it's their
Realization to meet you. I really appreciate time yeah, I can we can I get all your and forgetting some yourself
Yeah, yeah to do that. Well. I'll make it happen. Thank you in a world of unlimited vacation policy
unlimited
Like like I want to have all these macro conversations because this is what I'm thinking about of course it makes sense
Of course man like like there's so much like unlimited vacation policy has empowered this company to do good more than any company in
This market that alone I've accomplished everything one
show
get away, my dog I
Can 100% we were sent here? That's just so I
Need to know
the diagram of
Fame or that scratching that edge of notoriety or like you know that little start?
money
money uh
Legacy and and not the book like like like I would be reading material yeah, I'm
Yep, you're talking to guys very weird about this one like most imperative ones. We're cool
so then then you then they have to match so if you care about legacy if they leave a lot of money on the table
I need to know what the minimum number is
so that I can
Navigate that
Inconsistency in your story and or the map of what we should do
I won't give into spaSm makes their official 106 in stock, baby
I love you my location Target boy. Yeah
Hey focus the sky pausing care to me this
We looked there
She said come here
Should I just start tagging super left - instead of you? I'm fine with it. Do you like it?
It's fine like what I do you like getting the followers, teddy me being late hooked you guys up proper
Now you get to be on now you get to watch the askgaryvee show
Alright. I'll see a little bit. Do you you know it's funny. I got to tell you
I'm getting to know you more and more you know what I like about you and I what I really like about
Entrepreneurship a little bit and I'm hoping it continues to build momentum. Which is why I'm bringing it up right now I?
Like that people love it so much. They want to give back to the game one thing
I've always noticed from you is you always want to put on the young's like we see ourselves, right?
It's cool. I love it. I love it, too
Are you're really good at it enough that these?
Open-closed Savvy freaks painted those marbles the wrongs done
When I do some sort of thing on set next I will invite you in your duet
done
Roxas asked me for selfie videos to close out the episode follows a car. I said no
you